Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di Cucina Buttata, in occasione
del mese di giugno abbiamo pensato di
utilizzare la nostra prima ricetta per
celebrare questo mese del pride e quindi
fare una torta arcobaleno
- Sei daltonico (Enrico) - E te sei stro...
Per creare questa torta avremo bisogno di:
colorante alimentare, farina, uova, tante
tante uova, latte, panna da montare e
zucchero a velo
E come sempre...Quello che bisogna fare è un
preparato per crepes, e crep. Posso dire una
cosa? Oggi mi sento sul pezzo, questo
spirito di accettazione celebrativo
questa cosa per cui siamo uguali in
fondo, non scappare dai mie sbagli...vabbè
quello che dicevano ♬ Non scappare dai miei sguardi, non possono inseguirti ♬ - Non possono ferirti (E)
- Non possono, sennò perché doveva scappare, sennò faceva bene a scappare. Ho deciso questa
volta di utilizzare un altro tipo di
ricetta che è c***o de cane - Non puoi dire c***o
Alla sans de la sans, che può andar bene - Di cane (E)     - Di cane - Apro delle uova. Quante ce ne vanno?
Oh regà vanno delle uova, bisogna fare
un sacco di crepes perché bisognerà
metterle una sopra l'altra - Facciamo che
ti bippiamo ogni volta che dici il
quantitativo, quante uova mettiamo?
- Vorrei metterne (bip) o forse (bip). Secondo me possono bastare (bip) uova...Che ci siamo dimenticati?
- Il grembiule! (Francesca) - Giù mi lanci il grembiule...ok, andata - Adesso posso far vedere il quantitativo però
le sfoco - ... - Adesso mettiamo del latte, non so quanto
ne mettiamo...e sfochi quant'è? Capito non è che dobbiamo stare lì con
l'ansia, cioè regà delle crepes, ma che non le avete mai fatte?
- Non deve essere liquida...è un po'... (Giulia)
- Ok - Secondo me... (E) - Okok, appena hai detto "Non deve essere liquida" sei stata più che chiara - Gu ma
quanta farina ci stai a mette? - Mai quante parole metti tu all'interno di un video
Ce ne avrò messi un (bip) grammi
Lasciamo riposare le crepes, facciamo
un'analisi dei colori. Come dicevo questi
qui li ho presi su amazon e sono (bip) tipi
diversi di colori, infatti ho un po' di problemi
ho degli aiuti da casa perché dobbiamo
sceglierne (bip) in particolare - E i colori
dell'arcobaleno sono? - (bip). Ormai c'è tutto
quanto un discorso su quanti sono i
colori dell'arcobaleno della bandiera
LGBTQ. Sono un boato di più di colori
Quello che volevo fare io è semplicemente una torta
carina arcobalenosa. Il primo è rosso
- Wow! Questo qui è molto rosso, rosso scarlatto
- Guglielmo! (E)
- Questo è più aranciato
e questo è più aranciato. Adesso andiamo
alla scelta dell'arancione...Aspetta
- E' come quell'altro (E) - Ho un'idea ragazzi
Arancionino vero?...Questa cosa di giocare
coi colori è fichissima. Giallo limone è lui
Verde mela...questo è verde brancamenta, "E' varda brancamanta". Royal blu, ho un po' di paura
- Gu! (E) - No vi giuro non lo faccio apposta... - Wow! (E)  - Bello! (Giulia)
- Questo qui è viola...bello. Io a sensazione preferisco il rosa. Regà ha vinto
è più bello. L'unica cosa che però vorrei fare è
giusto per essere sicuri, è mischiare il rosso
- Melma? (E) - ... - O rosso agata? Non so se è un magenta o una cosa diversa eh
E' un po' debolino ragazzi...(bip)
E' un po' na m***a! Ok io ragazzi sono veramente tanto tanto daltonico, i miei occhi mi stanno mandando a
fare in...Quante ne vogliamo fare di
ognuno. (bip) di ogni colore ne facciamo
di crepes - Ma tu sei pazzo! E che è? (E)
Io non ho paura di osare e tu? Dov'è un coppino qua - Tieni Gu (E) - No quello è un
colino ragazzi. Vabbè andiamo a occhio, mezzo bicchiere è
un miracolo...Questo è troppo. Immaginati
che dobbiamo fare tante crepes una sopra
l'altra - Di colore diverso (Gianmarco) - Vuole fare (bip) crepes, è pazzo! - Vanno bene anche (bip)
per colore - Siamo sicuri di voler fare tutte le dosi? (E)     - Tanto nessuno poi le cucina ste cose che famo
Se prendo (bip) grammi e divido in (bip) quant'è che fa? (bip)... - Mamma mia guarda che cosa hai
fatto! - Ma come faccio? Non c'è un coppino!
- Mamma mia! (Enrico) - ... - Te credo che cambia colore (Gianmarco)
- Dai un altro pezzetto. Qua se caca come gli unicorni
Vi ricordate che ero stato bravissimo la
scorsa volta? Ma non mi sento altrettanto
bravo a sta botta - C'ha un odore di colorante (Gianmarco) - E' raccapricciante Gu (Enrico)
- Solo non ho portato il coppapasta
- Questa è bella (E)
- Sembra proprio il rumore da cesso otturato (Gianmarco) - E adesso l'arancione
- I piccioni questo è, vedi? (E) - Questo è color pesca (Beatrice) -
- Tutto color pesca per quella...Ma io mi ricordo che
quando abbiamo fatto le crepes la scorsa
volta... - secondo me hai sbagliato le dosi, quindi
seguite le dosi dell'altro video e anche la tecnica dell'altro video...Anzi, guardate direttamente... (E)
- Bello (G) - Questa però è bella piena (E) - Vedi alcune vengono di aspetto un pochino meglio, e poi... (G)
- Però ti posso dire una cosa?
E' bello così, non deve essere sempre
perfetto per essere perfetto...Caspita
questo è proprio giallo regà - Ok andiamo col verde
siete pronti? - "Passiamo in via Giovanni Conti Roma (Navigatore satellitare) - Guarda se in via Giovanni Conti
c'è una pasticceria...Questo è fichissimo!
- Ohh bello cavolo (E) - Questo è proprio un acquarello (G) - Un acquarello è quello che fai al cesso dopo
- Il momento però del colorante ripaga poi la cottura (G)  - Ripaga la cottura, si è vero. Si devono
pure raffreddare perché sennò ti smontano la panna
- Da quand'è che pensi alla panna montata te? (E) - Che vuol dire? -
- Cioè che non te ne curi mai, della panna - Non ti sei mai curato della panna (G)
- Non le hai mai voluto bene
- Ma è un video che ancora non è uscito (Francesca)        - Nono esce...è in diretta, cioè ci stanno vedendo
Anzi può inquadrarla un secondo che le
facciamo salutare tutte le persone all'ascolto
- Si, se vuoi salutare le persone all'ascolto... - Dai!
- Dai è andata! (G) - E' mortadella regà (E) - Abbiamo finito di cucinare le varie crepes, nel
frattempo montiamo la panna montata, da montare, sormontabile. Dov'è la nutella?
Non vogliamo dirvi qual è il nostro segreto
Mettiamo a sciogliere la nutella a bagnomaria
Ok...A me danno una felicità pazzesca
Che fico! Primo cerchio, forse avrei dovuto montarla un pochino di più
- Ma così tanta ne metti? (E) - E' difficilissimo, poi viaggia si muove - Comunque sta uscendo lo sbobbione (E)
- Aspè sta uscendo dal piatto - Guglielmo sta coprendo tutti i colori (Giulia) - E' una sensazione
veramente brutta dover andare avanti
nonostante tu veda la disfatta capito?
Non ce la faccio più!
- Gu ma sei totalmente fuori! (E) - Ma no sta
viaggiando. Ecco qua, è tornata e tornata - Dovevi...
livellarla meglio la panna, perché vedi così è
tutta storta (E) - Grazie Enrico...Non ti ispira?
Come non ti ispira?! - E' stata esclusivamente una tua idea questa torta, te lo ricordo (G)
- Ok, ora vi faccio vedere la grande idea che ho avuto. Spero proprio che non me la rubi in
pasticceria Giulia, puoi uscire
gentilmente?...E' arrivata la mossa "sans
de la sans". Prendiamo la panna e creiamo una
specie di nuvola qui, ritiro fuori i
coloranti... (bip bip bip)... (bip bip)
- Sei un genio! Io confido nell'opera finale Gu (E)
- Qualcuno che ha capito. Ok siamo pronti? Shaka shaka shaka
- Cioè, ci hai voluto mettere lo sbratto di unicorno (Giulia)
- Io credo che difficilmente si può fare una cosa più brutta
Dio santo che mostro!
Mi vergogno di me stesso
Forse sì forse è meglio toglierlo - Madonna, cioè
hai messo il colorante la sulla panna
- No - ... - E' carina, ma ragazzi come si fa ad assaggiare quella roba?!
- Nooo. Guarda che è carina così
Io suggerisco sinceramente di buttarci un po' di nutella
E passiamo agli assaggi, ragazzi venite qui. Dai Giammi, non vedi l'ora eh?
Mo dimmi che fa schifo
- Tutti i colori prendo - Prendi sisi
- Buona - Gianmarco sta per vomitare - No vabbè me la magno - Cioè nel senso è raccapricciante
alla vista ma di sapore c'è tutto - ... - Dai no... - Ragazze, dai che le crepes sono pronte
Aspetta...fidati te la taglio io...mettici della nutella sennò così
sbratti - E io? - La vuoi? - Certo! - Non avevo capito scusa - Ho assaggiato tutti gli orrori che hai cucinato
- Ma come si permette! Ammazza tutti a criticà ma ve la state a magnà
Ragazzi qui abbiamo tutti quanti gli zuccheri nel sangue, quindi
stiamo veramente vedendo i draghi. Io vi
invito a non provare assolutamente
questa ricetta, sappiate che è molto più
comodo farsi le crepes a casa
tranquillamente. L'ho fatto con piacere
per celebrare questo mese
Detto ciò qualora vi dovesse venire in
mente di farla taggatemi su Instagram
ma soprattutto iscrivetevi a questo
canale, attivate la campanella delle
notifiche se non volete perdervi i
prossimi video. Noi ci vediamo domenica
prossima sempre alle 12 con Cucina Buttata. Ciao